The salons of eighteenth-century France were not just places for powdered wigs and whispered
scandals.
They were laboratories of human manipulation.
The libertains, those dandies of decadence, had perfected an art form, the slow unraveling
of devotion to the cruel science of intermittent affection.
One day they would drown you in warmth, water, wine, the promise of eternity in your eyes.
The next they would vanish, leaving only the cold draft of their absence.
And you? You would wait.
You would hope, because hope, as it turns out, is the most reliable prison of all.
They understood something the rest of the world would only learn centuries later, in
a cage of steel and pigeons.
Unpredictability is the architect of obsession.
A reward given every time you press the lever is a chore.
But a reward that might come?
That is the definition of addiction.
The libertines didn't just play with hearts.
They rewired them, and now we turn this weapon inward.
This is not about seduction.
This is about dismantling.
Imagine, if you will, the Skinner Box, not as a cage for birds, but as the architecture
of your own mind.
You are the pigeon.
The lever is the faint, persistent belief that happiness might still be within reach.
And the food?
It arrives when it pleases.
Once a month, perhaps.
Or never.
The rest of the time, you peck.
You hope.
You stay in the box, because the alternative certainty, stability, the slow rod of depression,
is almost unbearable.
Better to be the moth, forever circling the flame, than to accept the dark.
The trick, of course, is to never let yourself settle.
If you wake up and horror of horrors, you feel good, you do not celebrate, you sabotage.
You reach for the resume of regrets.
Let the weight of your failures press down on you like a physical force.
You call your family anchor, that one person who knows just how to drag you back into the
muck.
The high is fleeting.
The crash is inevitable.
And in the wreckage, you rebuild the hope, because hope is the only thing that keeps you
pecking.
Then, once in a while, you allow yourself a crumb, a real meal, a walk in sunlight, but
never on your schedule.
Never when you expect it.
Randomness is the drug, and your brain is the junkie.
The other 95% of your life can be a wasteland of sedentary mastery work, routine, the slow
erosion of self with that one unpredictable moment.
That is the needle.
And you will do anything to chase it.
With others, the game is even simpler.
Be the most devoted friend for a single night.
Listen.
Comfort.
Make them feel seen.
Then vanish.
Not with drama, no.
That would be too easy.
Just silence.
A ghosting, slow and deliberate, like the fading of a candle.
They will chase you.
They will beg for the return of the warmth.
And when you deign to reappear, just long enough to offer another crumb of attention, they will
take it.
Because the alternative certainty, stability, the slow death of a normal relationship is
too much to bear.
And then there is the greatest trick of all, the mirage of tomorrow.
You are always about to change.
Tomorrow, you will start the diet.
Next week, you will quit the job.
The hope of the reward is the reward itself.
It lets you stay in the box one more day.
One more week.
One more year.
Because the moment you stop hoping, that is when the real work begins.
This is how you become the human piston.
Up and down, up and down, in a rhythm so familiar it feels like breathing.
Never bad enough to leave.
Never good enough to stay.
The moth at the light, forever hopeful, forever burned.
You have achieved the pinnacle of relational misery, a life that is the perfect balance of
agony and anticipation.
The doubt spiral is your cage, and the lever is the only thing that keeps you turning.
The residence log from May 27th captures it perfectly.
The subject rights of their own obsession, the uncertainty of their potential, the endless
pecking at the possibility that they might be okay.
And that, my friend, is the trap.
Hope is the only thing that can make misery eternal.
So you have a choice.
Kill it or keep it on a variable schedule.
Either way, you are still in the box.